my mom gave birth to me and they handed
me a bun me right away it's a lifestyle
the girls that get it get it
what's up everyone my name is twai and
welcome to making it big the show where
i turn your favorite foods giant today i
have my friend marco in the studio with
me and i think he has a challenge up his
sleeve so let's see what he got hey toy
what's up
i have something underneath here you and
i have done once before i have not you
know made it big i challenge you
to make the mama dough bon me oh this is
the mama dough bun me it's named after
my mom mama dough because this is her
recipe the name the cured pork in here
is hers and it was a collaboration
between open market and i and we fed
over how many people
250 when we first did it we were playing
around with two ideas and they were like
that tastes good this tastes good let's
eat this you're like oh my gosh like i
have this recipe my mom's let me bring
this in the pate the patway as we as we
called it when we first made it that's a
nice little key element and we tried it
and i was like this is it and then we
burst yeah
this sandwich uses your pate i'm gonna
need a lot of your pate how much like
10. 10 quarts yeah i'll make it happen
let's get started i had to change into
this shirt because this is the exclusive
collab tea between open market and i
this is a collage of my mom
had to wear it let's get started on the
bread which i'm really nervous about
because i actually didn't make the bread
for the collab so the fact that i have
to make a big giant one we're gonna see
i'm gonna start off by blooming my yeast
in water right here give it a little
stir let that sit ten and a half cups of
flour and this is only half this is so
much flour and then
and then salt it you're gonna have to
use a lot of salt i'm gonna whisk this
up and then my starter this have been
starting since last night it's just
yeast flour and water and then add the
yeast i don't specialize in bread making
because that's just not what i do okay i
had to take a bread making class in
culinary school there was one day where
i made literally the most perfect
baguette i got a perfect score so and
then after that i never got another
perfect score but that's okay really
glad that i didn't go to the gym today
because i'm about to get a workout in so
the dough is getting under my nails and
i'm kind of regretting the decision to
have nails it's a lifestyle the girls
that get it get it i was born in vietnam
i don't really remember the first time
i've had a bun meat my mom gave birth to
me and they handed me a bun me right
away so cheese looking gorgeous now i'm
about to transfer this
big boy into this bowl gonna grease it
first
[Music]
okay a little more grease
cover and then now we're gonna let our
dough baby take a nap for about 90
minutes 90 minutes is the perfect nap
time don't quote me on that though i
just saw it on the internet
and the baby has risen wow it grew so
much
this is so much dough okay i gotta get
the air bubbles out but i have not made
a bread this big so i'm really kind of
nervous about how this is going to turn
out i just don't know but i am doing my
best reminder this is just half of the
bun me all right so now i'm going to
fold it in the middle and
another roll oh did you see that i'm a
bread maker
and then i'm gonna pinch it together i
just gotta transfer this into
this baking tray
look at this i'm really proud of myself
i'm gonna spray
and then cover it and then i'm gonna let
this baby take a nap for about 45
minutes so far so good because look at
this i am very very proud of this now
we're gonna make slashes i'm not a bread
maker so don't judge me three two
ten slashes exactly
now we go to the oven in you go
good luck
[Music]
goodness
i'm so happy now one of the component in
the sandwich is pickle daikon and
carrots pickle daikon carrots is a
classic vietnamese pickle you will see
it literally everywhere so i'm going to
salt the veggies first now salting the
veggies for pickling is really important
so it can release the liquids and that
will make your pickle crunchy give this
a toss so the cuts on these veggies are
a little bit bigger well a lot bigger
than normal regular julienned cuts
because we're making it to scale this is
making it big so we're making it big i'm
gonna throw this in a strainer so when
the water pulls out from the veggies it
can just drop to the bottom of the bowl
and it's not sitting in its own juices
now we're gonna let this sit for like
five minutes so the water can drain to
the bottom of the bowl i'm going to
rinse this off in the sink so the
veggies aren't too salty i'm gonna
transfer the veggies into this and now
i'm gonna make the pickling liquid it's
just vinegar hot water i like to use hot
water because i'm about to put in some
sugar and that's really going to help
dissolve the sugar our sugar right here
and then a little bit of salt whisk this
up
and then i'm just going to pour it right
into the veggies and this can sit for 30
minutes the longer it sits the better it
is cover it let it sit and now this is
the star the cured pork sausage this is
my mom's recipe so it's very special to
me i never got to make it with her in
the kitchen because
she never let me in her kitchen but she
gave me the recipe so i have some pork
i have some pork bath pork back fat why
can't i say
i have some boiling water and i'm going
to add some pork back fat in while we're
waiting for this to cook i want to
introduce you guys to my little friend
over here her name is tiny tway and she
told me some really interesting facts
about bunnies did you know the word bun
me translates to wheat bread in vietnam
we literally just use bun me as a way to
describe bread i'm not sure where the
wheat bread is coming from but i'll give
tiny toy that one
this is now cooked and i'm going to
transfer it onto a tray
oh the smell can't lie to you i will
never get used to the smell i don't know
and then we're going to cool this down
to room temperature so it's time to put
this bad boy together so this is the
cooled pork back fat and i'm going to
just add it into my food processor
oh i like this thing this is a ground
pork belly i'm gonna add it straight
into here this is actually only a
quarter of one batch for one patty we
are making
two patties i'm gonna move over here to
my spices i have some water and baking
powder i'm gonna mix this up this is
really going to help tenderize the meat
add this right over the top i have fish
sauce a little bit of salt this is sugar
white pepper
and then this is pink curing salt this
is exactly my mom's recipe just just
bigger
and we
pose come on
okay wait i gotta
oh no
okay let's try to not break things
wow
okay wait it's really coming together
i have some shallots here i'm gonna add
into the mixture some garlic
this is looking so good i think my mom
would be proud and i am very happy with
this mixture let's make this patty this
is
actually 16 pounds of meat right here
so let's do it and that's only
one i'm not good at math how much is 16
plus 16.
32. oh man this is so much meat i
honestly did not know what to expect
when i was challenged to do this and i
didn't realize how oh there's more meat
in here
i just can't wait to see it come
together so i'm gonna pop this in the
oven and then i'm gonna start that
process all over again because this is
only the first patty
okay
16 pounds
of meat
in the oven
for one hour
now we're going to assemble the
lemongrass chili oil aioli this is my
special lemongrass chili oil i could
literally eat this by the spoonful it's
so good and now i'm going to add all of
this mayo this is the best mayo and i'm
going to add the whole bottle of the
best mayo to ever exist
in the world
so i'm just going to fold this in look
at that color
so for the pop-up i also had to do a big
batch of this aioli i just feel like i'm
reliving that day all over again but
it's cool because it was a really fun
day
now that's what good aioli sounds like
this is done now it's about time we get
to assemble this sandwich i'm so hyped
first we need to cut the bread all right
i have to really make sure that it's
even all the way through
wow
this looks so good
smells good i'm going to put the pate on
the bottom a very generous amount pate
is very important you need to have pate
in a bun meat if you don't have pate in
a by me i don't know if it's even
considered a bun me i'm sorry so pate
for those that don't know it's basically
seasoned to liver that's blended down
into really nice
mousse like consistency we get to lay
our meat on this nice bed of pate i
can't believe this is so much meat i'm
very happy with the char on this this is
perfect why are you so perfect now we
move on to our aioli making sure every
single crevice has some aioli and then a
sprinkle a little bit of crispy shallots
on here this is coming out better than i
thought it would i think i'm killing it
then i'm going to put pickled daikon and
carrots on top of the meat we cut up
three big english cucumbers for this i
feel like i'm dealing cards right now i
hope marco is gonna like this i spent a
lot of time on this so he better that
looks so cute and over here we have a
special herb called vietnamese coriander
this is called raurum in vietnamese and
it's very specific it has just a
distinct taste and smell to it that you
just can't get it anywhere else it
doesn't even taste like regular
coriander to begin with it's kind of
lickerishy and now i get to crown my
sandwich three
two
[Music]
that's the sandwich
this is actually only half of the
sandwich i have to do another one and
i'm really excited to see how this is
going to turn out oh my gosh i'm a bit
overwhelmed right now because i knew it
was gonna be big but this is
big i can't wait to show marco this
because i don't even think he'd
understand how big this is let's bring
him back marco lolo whoa
yeah you did make it big and then you
made it into one fatty yes oh my gosh
this is so big but does it look like the
mama does it it does it just looks
gigantic so now the question is does it
taste like the mama dough oh my gosh
this is what you challenged me to do
this is my execution that is crazy
cheers i feel like i had to give you
space there it is that's a mama dough
salad
you gotta go for it
oh my gosh
this is indeed a mama dub i mean if you
take a look at it you hit like all spots
there's pate on the bottom you got your
chili oil bringing the heat you got all
those pickles got the meat it's cooked
really nicely it's really good this has
been very motivating because i really
didn't think that i could do it but i
did it it's like you didn't like start
off with being like okay i'm gonna make
one sandwich bed you're like no i'm
gonna make the biggest sandwich bread
that i could possibly do by looking at
this sandwich how many pounds of meat do
you think this is
10. one patty is actually 16 16 pounds
well this has definitely been a journey
but a fun one so thank you for the
challenge in the comments let us know
what we should make big next did you use
all the pate by the way no i didn't
that's for me that's for you okay so it
was like two quarts of this eight quarts
[Music]